hey what's up uh okay  so last year i had a chance to be a part  of team oscar and give a group of young  filmmakers  an opportunity to come to hollywood and  to appear on stage at the academy awards  which was an honor  so i'm happy to announce that i get to  come back and do it again um  all right so i guess i'm going to  personally invite you to join me  on february 22nd at this year's oscar  ceremony  now how do you enter the team oscar  contest  you enter by making a 60-second movie on  the best piece of advice that you have  ever heard  all right you enter through facebook.com  backslash  the academy all right we'll be looking  for the  most creative video submissions so i  can't wait to see what you guys come up  with  all right good luck and i hope to see  you all there bye